good evening
ella baker a giant of the civil rights
movement
left us with this wisdom give people
light
and they will find the way give people
light
those are words for our time the current
president has cloaked
american darkness for much too long
too much anger too much fear too much
division
here and now i give you my word
if you entrust me with the presidency i
will draw on the best of us
not the worst i'll be an ally of the
light
not the darkness it's time for us
for we the people to come together
and make no mistake united we can and
will
overcome this season of darkness in
america we'll choose hope over fear
facts over fiction fairness over
privilege
i'm a proud democrat and i'll be proud
to carry the banner of our party into
the general election
shows with great honor and humility i
accept this nomination
for president of the united states of
america
but while i'll be a democratic candidate
i will be an american president
i'll work hard for those who didn't
support me as hard for them as i did for
those who
did vote for me that's the job of a
president
to represent all of us not just our base
or our party
this is not a partisan moment this must
be an american moment
it's the moment the calls for hope and
light and love
hope for our future light to see our way
forward
and love for one another america isn't
just a collection of
clashing interests of red states or blue
states
we're so much bigger than that we're so
much better than that
no nearly a century ago franklin
roosevelt
pledged a new deal in a time of massive
unemployment
uncertainty and fear stricken by a
disease
stricken by a virus fdr insisted that he
would recover
and prevail and he believed america
could as well
and he did and we can as well
this campaign isn't just about winning
votes it's about winning the heart and
yes the soul of america
went in it for the generous among us not
the selfish
wanting it for workers to keep this
country going not just the privileged
few at the top
winning it for those communities who
have known the injustice of a knee on
the neck
for all the young people have known only
america
being rising in equity and shrinking
opportunity
they deserve the experience of america's
promise
they deserve to experience it in full
you know no generation ever knows what
history will ask of it
all we can ever know is whether we're
ready
when that moment arrives and now history
has delivered us
to one of the most difficult moments
america's ever faced
four four historic crises all at the
same time
a perfect storm the worst pandemic in
over a hundred years
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
the most compelling call for racial
justice since the 60s
and the undeniable realities and
just the accelerating threats of climate
change
so the question for us is simple are we
ready
i believe we are we must be
you know all elections are important we
know in our bones this one is more
consequential
as many have said america is at an
inflection point
a time of real peril but also
extraordinary possibilities
we can choose a path of becoming angrier
less hopeful
more divided a path of shadow and
suspicion
or or we can choose a different path and
together
take this chance to heal to reform to
unite
a path of hope and light this is a
life-changing election
this will determine what america is
going to look like for a long long time
character is on the ballot compassion is
on the ballot
decency science democracy they're all
on the ballot who we are as a nation
what we stand for most importantly who
we want to be
that's all on the ballot
and the choice could not be more clear
no rhetoric is needed just judge this
president on the facts
five million americans infected by covet
19.
more than 170 000 americans have died
by far the worst performance of any
nation on earth
more than 50 million people have filed
for unemployment this year
more than 10 million people are going to
lose their health insurance this year
nearly one in six small businesses have
closed
this year and this president
if he's reelected you know what will
happen
cases and deaths will remain far too
high
more mom-and-pop businesses will close
their doors and this time for good
working families will struggle to get by
and yet the wealthiest one percent
will get tens of billions of dollars in
new tax breaks
and the assault on the affordable care
act will continue until it's destroyed
taking insurance away from more than 20
million people
including more than 15 million people on
medicaid
and getting rid of the protections that
president obama worked so hard to get
past
for people who have 100 million more
people
who have pre-existing conditions and
speaking of president obama
a man i was honored to serve alongside
for eight years as vice president
let me take this moment to say something
we don't say nearly enough
thank you mr president you were a great
president
a president of our children could and
did look up to
no one's going to say that about the
current occupant of the white house
what we know about this president is if
he's given four more years
he'll be what he's been for the last
four years
president takes no responsibility
refuses to lead
blames others cozies up to dictators and
fans the flames of hate and division
he'll wake up every day believing the
job is all about him
never about you is that the american you
want
for you your family your children
i see a different america one that's
generous and strong
selfless and humble it's an american we
can rebuild together
as president the first step i will take
we to get control of the virus that has
ruined so many lives
because i understand something this
president hasn't from the beginning
we will never get our economy back on
track we will never get our kids safely
back in schools
we'll never have our lives back until we
deal with this virus
the tragedy of where we are today is it
didn't
have to be this bad just look around
it's not this bad in canada or europe or
japan
or almost anywhere else in the world
and the president keeps telling us the
virus is going to disappear
he keeps waiting for a miracle well i
have news for him
no miracle is coming
we lead the world in confirmed cases
lead the world in deaths
our economy is in tatters with black
latino asian american native american
communities
burying the brunt of it and after
all this time the president still does
not have a plan
well i do if i'm your president
on day one will implement the national
strategy i've been laying out since
march
we'll develop and deploy rapid tests
with results available immediately we'll
make the medical supplies and protective
equipment that our country needs
and we'll make them here in america so
we will never again
be at the mercy of china or other
foreign countries in order to protect
our own people
we'll make sure our schools have the
resources they need
to be open safe and effective
we'll put politics aside we'll take the
muzzle off
our experts so the public gets the
information
they need and deserve honest unvarnished
truth
they can handle it
we'll have a national mandate to wear a
mask not as a burden but as a patriotic
duty to protect one another
in short we'll do what we should have
done from the very beginning
our current president has failed in his
most
basic duty to the nation he's failed to
protect us
he's failed to protect america and my
fellow americans
that is unforgivable as president i'll
make you a promise
i'll protect america i will defend us
from every attack
seen and unseen always without exception
every time
look i understand i understand how hard
it is to have any hope right now
on this summer night let me take a
moment to speak to those of you who have
lost the most i have some idea how it
feels to lose someone you love
i know that deep black hole that opens
up in the middle of your chest and you
feel like you're being sucked into
it i know how mean
and cruel and unfair
life can be sometimes
but i've learned two things first
your loved one may have left this earth
but they'll never leave your heart
they'll always be with you you'll always
hear them
and second i found the best way through
pain and loss and grief
is to find purpose as god's children
each of us have a purpose in our lives
we have a great purpose as a nation
to open the doors of opportunity to all
americans
to save our democracy to be a light to
the world once again
and finally to live up to and make real
the words written in the sacred
documents that founded this nation
that all men and women are created equal
endowed by their creator with certain
inalienable rights among them
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
you know my dad was an honorable decent
man
he got knocked down a few times pretty
hard but he always got back up
he worked hard and he built a great
middle class life for our family
he used to say joey i don't expect the
government to solve my problems but i
sure in hell expect them to understand
them
and then he'd say joey a job is about a
lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect
it's about your place in the community
it's about being able to look your kid
in the eye and say honey
it's gonna be okay and mean it
i've never forgotten those lessons
that's why my economic plan is all about
jobs
dignity respect and community
together we can and will rebuild our
economy
and when we do we'll not only build back
we'll build back better with modern
roads
bridges highways broadband ports and
airports
as a new foundation for economic growth
with pipes that transport clean water
to every community with five million new
manufacturing
and technology jobs so the future is
made in america
well the health care system that lowers
premiums deductibles
drug prices by building on the
affordable care act he's trying to rip
away
with an education system that trains our
people for the best jobs of the 21st
century there's not a single thing
american workers can't do and where
cost doesn't prevent young people from
going to college
and student debt doesn't crush them when
they get out
with the child care and elder care
system that makes it possible for
parents to go to work
and for the elderly to stay in their
homes with dignity
with an immigration system that powers
our economy and reflects our values
and with newly empowered labor unions
they're the ones that built the middle
class
with equal pay for women with rising
wages
you can raise a child on a family on
and yes we're going to do more than
praise our essential workers
we're finally going to pay them pay them
we can and we will deal with climate
change
it's not only a crisis it's an enormous
opportunity an opportunity for america
to lead the world in clean energy
and create millions of new good paying
jobs
in the process and we can pay for these
investments
by ending loopholes unnecessary
loopholes and the president's 1.3
trillion dollar tax giveaway
to the wealthiest one percent and the
biggest most profitable corporations
some of which
do not pay any tax at all
because we don't need a tax code that
rewards wealth
more than it rewards work
i'm not looking to punish anyone far
from it
but it's long past time the wealthiest
people and the biggest corporations in
this country
paid their fair share and for our
seniors
social security is a sacred obligation
a sacred promise made they paid for
the current president is threatening to
break that promise
he's proposing to eliminate a tax that
pays for almost
half the social security without any way
of making up for that lost revenue
resulting in cuts i will not let that
happen
if i'm your president we're going to
protect social security and
medicare you have my word
one of the most powerful voices we hear
in the country today
is from our young people they're
speaking to the inequity and injustice
that has grown up in america
economic injustice racial injustice
environmental injustice i hear their
voices if you listen you can hear them
too
and whether it's the exidential
existential threat posed by climate
change
the daily fear being gunned down in
school
or the inability to get started in your
first job
it will be the work of the next
president to restore the promise
of america to everyone
and i'm not going to have to do it alone
because i'll have a great
vice president at my side senator kamala
harris
she's a powerful voice for this nation
her story is the american story
she knows about all the obstacles thrown
in the way of so many in our country
women black women black americans
south asian americans immigrants the
left out and the left behind
but she's overcome every obstacle she's
ever faced
no one's been tougher on the big banks
than a gun on the gun lobby
no one's been tougher in calling out the
current administration for its extremism
it's failure to follow the law it's
failure to simply
tell the truth
kamal and i both draw from our families
that's we get our strength for commons
doug
and their families for me it's jill and
ours
i've said many times no man deserves one
great love in his life let alone two
but i've known two after losing my first
wife in that car accident
jill came into my life she put our
family back together
she's an educator a mom a military mom
and an unstoppable force if she puts her
mind to it
just get out of the way she's going to
get it done
she was a great second lady and i know
she'll make a great first lady for this
nation she loves this country so much
and i'll always have the strength that
can only come from family
hunter ashley all our grandchildren
my brothers my sister they give me
courage they lift me up
while he's no longer with us
bo inspires me every day
both served our nation in uniform a year
in iraq a decorated
iraqi war veteran so i take very
personally
and i the profound responsibility of
serving as commander-in-chief
i'll be a president who will stand with
our allies and friends and make it clear
to our adversaries
the days of cozying up to dictators is
over
under president biden america will not
turn a blind eye to russian bounties
on the heads of american soldiers nor
light put up with foreign interference
on our most
sacred democratic exercise voting
and i'll always stand for our values
of human rights and dignity a working
common purpose
for a more secure peaceful and
prosperous world
history history has thrust one more
urgent task on us
will we be the generation that finally
wipes out the stain of racism
from our national character i believe
we're up to it
i believe we're ready just a week ago
yesterday was the third anniversary of
the events in charlottesville
close your eyes remember what you saw on
television remember seeing
those neo-nazis and klansmen and white
supremacists
coming out of fields with lighted
torches
veins bulging spewing the same same
anti-semitic bile
heard across europe in the 30s
remember the violent clash that ensued
between those spreading hate
and those with the courage to stand
against it
and remember what the president said
when asked
he said there were quote very fine
people on both sides
it was a wake-up call for us as a
country and for me
a call to action at that moment i knew
i'd have to run
because my father taught us that silence
was complicity and i could never remain
silent or complicit
at the time i said we're in the battle
for the soul of this nation
and we are
you know one of the most important
conversations i've had this entire
campaign
it was something this was someone who
was much too young to vote
i met with six-year-old gianna floyd the
day before her daddy
george floyd was laid to rest she's an
incredibly brave little girl
i'll never forget it when i leaned down
to speak to her
she looked in my eyes and she said i
quote daddy
changed the world
daddy changed the world
her words burrowed deep into my heart
maybe george floyd murder was a breaking
point
maybe john lewis is passing the
inspiration
but however has come to be however it's
happened
america is ready in john's words to lay
down quote the heavy
burden of hate at last
and then the hard work
of rudy now our systemic racism
you know american history tells us that
it's been on our darkest moments
that we've made our greatest progress
that we found the light and this dark
moment
i believe we're poised to make great
progress again
that we can find the light once more
you know many people have heard me say
this but i've always believed you can
define
america in one word possibilities
to defining feature america everything
is possible
that in america everyone and i mean
everyone
should be given an opportunity to go as
far as their dreams and god-given
ability will take them
we can never lose that in times as
challenging as these
i believe there's only one way forward
as a united america a united america
united in our pursuit of a more perfect
union
united in our dreams of a better future
for us and for our children united in
our determination
to make the coming years bright
are you ready i believe we are
this is a great nation we're a good and
decent people
for lord's sake this is the united
states of america
and there's never been anything we've
been able to accomplish
when we've done it together
the irish poet sheamus heaney once wrote
history says don't hope on this side of
the grave
but then once in a lifetime
the longed for tidal wave of justice can
rise up
and hope and history rhyme
this is our moment to make hope and
history rhyme
with passion and purpose let us begin
you and i together
one nation under god unite our love for
america united in our love for each
other
for love is more powerful than hate hope
is more powerful than fear
and light is more powerful and dark this
is our moment
this is our mission may history be able
to say
that the end of this chapter of american
darkness began here
tonight as love and hope and light
join in the battle for the soul of the
nation
and this is a battle we will win and
we'll do it together
i promise you thank you and may god
bless you
and may god protect our troops good
night